hello to our viewers I'm here in our CBS
this morning Toyota greenroom with actor
and comedian what's your name Tracy
Morgan Tracy Morgan he's known for his
roles and impressive but they call me
dinger Washington Julia but well how
would you like to be addressed today
Denzel or Tracy or what Sydney for 40
years
is known for shows including Def Comedy
Joe can I change that okay
two-time Emmy nominated Tracy Walker
well can I get to that part I'm sorry
def Comedy Jam Saturday Night Live in 30
rock he currently stars in the last oh
gee which is filmed in the same Brooklyn
neighborhood where he grew up so we
heard Tracy's heartfelt message to its
six year old self earlier today it's
part of our ongoing series note to self
where he reflected on his childhood his
comedy career and the life lessons he's
learned along the way we are pleased to
have two-time Emmy nominated Tracy
Morgan join us in the green Tracy it's
so good to see you the Knights is the
note to self that we do is really one of
the most popular features we do here and
I find for most people it's very
cathartic for them to write it it's
painful for them to write it sometimes
it's reflective you started with your
six year old self was this a difficult
note for you to do people are very moved
by it and I want to say to you listeners
and viewers it's it's playing right now
you can call it up right now on the CBS
this morning website but don't do that
until we hear what Tracy has to say was
it difficult for you to write it Tracy
yeah yes your life is is you be living
although the not just painful but it was
glorious too because you know we had
good times growing up my dad was there
my mom was there you know we had good
time but it's also a traumatic point
because that's that's the point where my
dad left the home mm-hmm well your mom
made the decision for you she had to
because she wanted her children why he
was an intravenous drug user he didn't
go to Vietnam a drug user he came back
that way but nonetheless she had to
protect her children and you know my mom
is a protect that's my mother and I love
you mommy
but she had to do what was best for her
kids because we will mimic me and my
brother we were mimicking our dad you
said your dad was funny like Richard
Pryor whoa whoa he
have more talent in one pinky then I
have in my whole body he could do
dialect he could do all kind of stuff he
travelled the world I'm just a better
businessman Tracy when did you know that
you were funny considering the Batcave
had high school high school what
happened before that it was a lot of
trauma it was a lot of running away from
it was a lot of that it was odd me my
dad it was a lot of that yeah when I
went I ran away from home at 13 wake it
up
where'd you got went to my father uh-huh
I knew at that point at that age I
needed him yeah what my friend if I had
man I would my might be a statistic like
the rest of my friends yeah a lot of
them became not all of them but a lot of
them became statistics to where we were
raised the environment all that and I
wanted my father yeah I wanted my father
he's the only one in this world I could
show me how to be a man did he bring
that I am now did he want you at 13 when
yeah she never left I mean my mom broke
up but he was always in his kid's life
four of us he was always there he was
always a great dad always kind of I
could remember him maybe beating us once
and my whole life and that's because he
bought a brand-new carpet in the house
and me and my brother spilled a little
bit we call ourselves making some
Catholic lunch and I spilled a little
bit of milk we went got buckets of water
through the coffee he woke up into the
ceiling so I had some but it's fine I
can get you for that daddy
he deserved my dad yeah my dad was such
a man he loved his kids that we did do
something wrong going through that
knucklehead sage it was a look yeah it
was a look I was more it was a look so
he cuz he trusted us and what hurt me
what would hurt me was that I let him my
mom down I would hurt me more what do
you mean if I did something to let them
down okay give me that look like yeah
that hurt you more yes sometimes a look
is worse than actually getting a second
I'd you know you get your dad clearly
had an impact on you you sought him out
you knew you were funny my mom did too I
think my mom had the biggest impact on
me how I know what I get from her but
her stubbornness I refused to take no
for an answer
that's why I'm sitting where I'm at
because when I got into show business
I'm
who tried to tell you know Tracy Morgan
the world mm-hmm the world when I was
born the world no not you you ain't
gonna make it
mm-hmm that's what you taught growing up
you know being black in America and all
that you know what is the chance of you
get a star to walk Hollywood wrong but I
got that from my mother
at least warning yeah and you said oh
you're not giving up nah she had five
kids
yeah she did we good all kids are good
people with righteous folk she did a
damn good job mommy you did mommy you
did a really good job cuz Tracey's
sitting here today cuz nobody tells him
no I want to go back to high school with
me no you won't accept no you won't
accept no so what happened in high
school that made you say hey I could do
some up here's what did you do I want to
make them live being on the football
team you know the track team you know
like uh snapping on each other joking on
each other and then I started getting
the girls you know you get the girls you
make the girls laugh you get the girls
get the girls cuz I don't care you act
any woman in the world would she love
most in any man that's a sense of humor
it's so true there's such a you know
it's so true that's a sense of humor so
I had a great sense of humor and then I
have friends like Leroy and sobs leave
our Williams and stops and on a football
team and we know just snapping on each
other we had such me I was a diva Clint
in the Bronx that's a very procedure
school you got Nobel Peace Prize winners
that come out of a saloon yeah you
Charles Rangel went to that school you
had a funny line in note to self where
you said you could make the drug dealers
and the gangsters in the neighborhood
laugh so you're not gonna be afraid of a
heckler always trying to take you down
you make a person laugh that just came
home from doing 15 years in prison you
make them laugh crack up you could I was
revered
I just I was protected I was revered you
know I got a name up in Rutgers in
Harlem you being funny being funny and
then one day was the drug dealer took me
to the comedy club ah and at the comedy
club you saw what what did you see that
thank you other people don't
munna for well I first my man Raul took
me my brother to Def Jam the first year
and I saw more on Lawrence and he looked
like me and he sounded
he's choking on things that I can
identify and relate with and something
came over me up in them stands and I
started doing comedy I started doing
comedy then one day we went to great
adventures and my one of my son's won a
propeller hat and I thought that would
be to get America's attention I put that
on I was funny with the hat on
hey buddy teddy bear Tracey teddy bear
Morgan may God bless the dead my man I
died in the accident Jim and he's the
very first person I met professionally
in show business he was letting the
workshop up in Harlem I was standing
with my man might say go to the workshop
I went to a workshop and guess who
walked up Jimmy Mack he said you here
for the workshop I said yeah he said my
name is Jimmy Mack and from that
handshake you guys were tight yeah yeah
yeah he showed me the gay yeah show me
the game but he was more than I was he
was like a person like much like my dad
was working through him to touch me I've
heard you say that you still believe
Jimmy looks out for you and your dad one
of my strongest angels looks out for you
yeah my dad my ex-wife that passed away
last year Sabina yeah they stay with me
they didn't you know what brings me
solace they don't know I'm gonna see
them again but that will be my reward
when he welcomes me into his kingdom
again yeah when he well then they
waiting on me we don't want that anytime
soon no I got a fourth Bobby old
daughter I got a raise and sons so
they're fine but it is interesting Tracy
when my mom died over said to me that
when somebody close to you dies you know
that there's there's an angel in heaven
who knows your name and that gave me a
lot of comfort and that makes me think
you have your dad yeah you have Jimmy
and you have Sabina that's what makes me
think about you you know I thought what
was interesting in the note to self this
morning beautifully produced by Dana
Burlington to Dana but in the thing
because I was I gotta tell you I didn't
know what was coming on this morning so
when my boy Ben caught me say I was
about to come on in a minute and I
turned it on and I just broke down
crying why I was good drugs cuz it was
my whole life yeah I should write before
me yeah picture my dad it was Sabina was
making it was didn't when I see my
daughter mmm the Tracy you told
beautiful life story though I told the
truth yeah but it was a beautiful life
yeah but it wasn't meant to be beautiful
I told the truth that's more important
to me mm-hmm it's all the truth you
talked about what surprised me was
you're growing up watching as you said
old white ass movies what did you say
old white ass movie oh yeah because To
Kill a Mockingbird was one of your
favorite father
I just Tracy Morgan yeah my six
yeah I well they're white people happen
to be in them but to me they're classics
I like classics you don't said that
Sunset Boulevard you know your Lost
Weekend you know yeah but just think of
you growing up looking at those movies
saying I like it
thinking did you think I want to be an
actor you just thought I really liked
what's happening here I like what's
happening here
yeah I like to act it was Alice in
Wonderland it was carwash
mm-hmm it was all that it was studying
at that age you know it's studying you
talk about Jimmy because you were in the
news with the Walmart accident in the
Walmart truck and you tell a very
touching story about learning to walk
because we almost lost you Tracy you
almost didn't make it but you did and
you talked about you and your daughter
learning to walk at the same time yeah
remember that day 14 oh I forgive him I
okay okay go ahead it's all right
TBR and honor but I remember she was in
the hallway and I've been appointed she
was standing and I was in my wheelchair
and she was I remember I first came home
she would be scared of the wheelchair
she wouldn't come to me in her Walker
she was trying right at me and my wife
told me Tracy's just scared of the
wheelchair mm-hmm I didn't know I didn't
know so she got used to it she knew I
was daddy then she started getting her
balance she was standing
then one day was nighttime and I was in
the hallway the remember what room in
the long hallway and she started walking
down the hallway and I went crazy I
started screaming I started screaming
and my wife came running upstairs and
she walked back and forth a few times
isolating for that I got up my wife with
nuts my wife's crying
don't do it and I just stood up
just stood there hold the wall when you
came through the accident make it did
you say that you would make it no when
she started ain't think that I was here
I knew I was alive when I came out to
coma I was alive after I started to know
that I was alive
cuz I don't remember that so but once I
knew I was alive I didn't know my name
yeah my wife said when I came out to
coma I was blind for a week I messed up
two neurons in my brain mm-hmm they're
not that I don't quite remember seeing
anybody I just know that I'm here now I
don't remember that whole part of my
life is like a blank but I was alive
yeah then the guilt started to come in
while survived by Jimmy there ain't I
actually be then all that start to
happen
mm-hmm all that started to happen well
there's a reason I didn't know my name
did I had to get cut with a cognitive
therapy yeah I had to learn how to count
my wife said that she was there one day
and a lady said what color is this and I
said green and it was paint I was in so
you really had to learn all over but
here you are Tracy's living here I did
not walk on sand my femur was in little
pieces yeah we can still see some of the
scars oh yeah we can so see this one was
bad that baby's skin all of this goes on
that but you sit here today in 2018 you
have a hit show you and Tiffany and og
mm-hmm so clearly you can read you can
shout Bobby baby yes yes I mean so
you're sitting here you have a hit show
and it seems like Tracy Morgan is in a
really good place now is he I still got
what you do I mean it sure I love it is
beautiful but if it means for some part
of me is bigger than that it's bigger
than that I got a help
I got a help I got a help others I mean
what street is the Ronald McDonald House
on 79th seventy third last week I was
just compelled I always go there to help
the kids to go there on my dime yeah but
I broke down at my calling after y'all
job and I just got off a 79 chef so he
not went near that said what help just
crying I'm gonna have just walked in off
the street what a help some his kids
would know
on their humble kids I wanna help so if
you out there any hospital in your
neighborhood just go to the children's
ward just go help because it's the only
way out of the darkness and I said it
yesterday only way out of the darkness
is I think I put yourself in service
yeah
you will forget about the crap you doing
if you help in the only way out of the
doc people do tell me that Tracy Morgan
is a lot more emotional these days I saw
you at the I can basically yeah I'm not
all day I don't cry forgive me I can be
if I can still cry that means I've still
got something inside when you can't cry
is well you better start worrying that
means you call it an empty inside well
you were certainly not cold and empty
inside well I just wanna be a part of
the problem though I'm gonna be a
prosecutor I wanna be a part of the
solution not the problem I cried two
weeks ago but I seen Trump and kill me
sit down
yeah and I'm 49 years old I've never
heard nor heard of state no no had a
state no politician a world leader see
the word peace and I heard the word
peace mm-hmm you feel optimistic about
what's going on I'm not going here okay
okay I'm just saying I heard the word
peace so I'm going with that yeah yeah I
think we got to put the guns down
that little boy in the bronze some more
men gasp we got to put the guns down
that's why I did what I did in Marcy
projects because that's the playground
is a safe place for kids to get away
from all of this that I played in that
Park I lost friends in that Park and I
made it clear to TBS yeah I gave you a
his shelf now I want something but what
do you want mr. Morgan I want to
renovate that part so maybe we could
start doing that maybe it'd be a trend
for other celebrities other four people
were more fortunate others I will say
this trace it cuz we might have to do a
special report because of what's going
on in the Supreme Court mm-hmm but what
I say this about you
you use your celebrity for good always
you always have and so we are cheering
you on we thank you so much for you know
I love you too we thank you so much for
doing the know yourself and you were a
pendant that's
number one dad because dad means a lot
to you Tracy Morgan thank you I don't
right on right on right on